after three years
my girlfriends just still ask me
what I study and how I handle it
is an explanation
me making computers do stuff for me
or that I take care of it
that computers do things for other people
and how that works is that you learn a language
for example as you would learn German or French
but not to communicate with people
but to communicate with computers
if you have eventually learned that language
so you can make cool things
such as a website or an application
I am also of grade
and on this account I'm going to tell you how it is
to study computer science
and things around it that interest me
so feel free to watch the coming period
for example,
if you also study yourself or for no reason
always fine bye